this video is brought to you by
brilliant.org hi welcome to another
episode of Cold Fusion in recent times
we've only seen incremental advancements
in the field of science and technology
that was until Sam Altman's open AI
ushered in a new era for artificial
intelligence an open AI is the company
of course behind the artificial
intelligence tool chat GPT that is the
potential to revolutionize how people
work shop and interact I've been
covering open AI on Cold Fusion since
the middle of 2017 at this time their
bot bit dendy a professional Dota 2
player in a 1v1 match at a major Esports
tournament since then the technology has
only gotten better the next thing I
covered from open AI was their dextrose
robot
many years later The Firm brought out
their smash hit AI generator darli
followed closely by its text generator
chat GPT and this has now become a
global sensation we've talked about chat
gbt and all of these things at length
but what is hardly ever talked about is
Sam Altman himself the main man leading
the revolution in AI those who are
following along in the technology space
either see him as a villain or the
future savior of the world in today's
episode we'll take a look at Altman's
history his inner psyche and his
motivations for launching the company
open AI
you are watching telefusion TV
AI news is everywhere at the moment so
wouldn't it make sense to know how it
works that's where today's sponsor
brilliant.org comes in it's the best way
to learn stem subjects brilliant has an
interactive course on computer science
which includes neural networks you can
read about AI or you want but brilliant
actually tests your learning and
understanding in a fun way if you're
looking to brush up on your stem
knowledge or just want to satisfy your
curiosity brilliant can help you reach
your goals I particularly enjoyed the
introduction to neural networks course
it was a great refresher and really
solidifies the building blocks of what
Sam Altman is talking about go to
brilliant.org coldfusion or click the
link in the description to get a 30-day
free trial the first 200 people will get
20 off their annual subscription
okay so back to the video
Sam Oldman was born on April 22nd 1985
in Chicago Illinois as a child he was
incredibly curious and had a passion for
Science and Technology at just the age
of eight he got his first computer a
Macintosh SE that computer became his
gateway to the world he would soon
discover AOL chat rooms it was
transformational for him in his early
development as a person
although precocious and nerdy he was
quite a bold kid at the age of 16 he
would come out to his parents as
homosexual at the time he was attending
John Burroughs School a private prep
school in St Louis Missouri
there were incidents at the school about
his sexuality that caused him to think a
bit differently and challenge the world
with new ideas
[Music]
after graduating high school he got into
Stanford University to study computer
science soon though with two of his
classmates he started developing a
mobile app called looped this was the
early era of Facebook and Twitter
everyone was curious about what each
other was up to and what was on their
mind but no one was able to share their
location just yet
looped was based on this exact idea it
told your friends where you were
although somewhat frowned upon for
security reasons today back then in the
early 2000s it was a cool and novel idea
looped was one of the first mobile apps
that allowed users to share their
location selectively with other people
to give you some context Google Maps was
launched in 2005 but its location
sharing feature was added in 2017.
Twitter and Facebook implemented the
feature in 2009 and 2010 respectively
seeing the potential ultimate dropped
out of Stanford in 2005 to establish his
company but what he would need was a
substantial amount of investment to
further develop the product
luckily he received funding from Y
combinator and Sequoia capital
at this point remember the name y
combinator it will be a major part of
Sam Altman's life which we'll cover in
the next part of the episode
in the summer of 2005 Altman worked
tirelessly he was meeting with mobile
carriers and convincing them to feature
the app
back then there was no app store neither
Google nor Apple was providing a service
like that remember smartphones look like
this
so knocking on the mobile carrier's
doors was the only option
his hard work did soon pay off and the
app's valuation Rose to 175 million
despite the valuation consumers never
bought the app Altman later would say to
the New Yorker quote we had the
optimistic view that location would be
all important the pessimistic view was
that people would lie on their couches
and just consume content and that is
what happened
end quote in 2012 he and other Founders
sold the company for 43 million after
selling the company he broke up with his
long-term partner Nick sivo who was also
the co-founder of looped so this was a
major setback both in his personal and
professional life despite the blow he
made a name for himself
remember why combinator a seed stage
Venture firm that has funded many
successful startups like Reddit Airbnb
Dropbox twitch and Sam Altman's now
obscure looped Altman had failed to
establish his first company but he had
caught the attention of Paul Graham the
co-founder of Y combinator looped was
one of the first eight companies that
wire combinator funded Paul Graham was
impressed by Sam's tonicity an
entrepreneurial spirit
he asked Sam to become a part-time
partner at Y combinator in 2011. Altman
joined and helped build key parts of the
Y combinator experience for founders
later in 2014 he'd become president when
Paul Graham and his co-founder wife
Jessica Livingston stepped down to look
after their two young children
[Music]
ultimate is a force to be reckoned with
he has a calm demeanor but sometimes
that can be replaced with a frightening
temper but that's only when it's crossed
his quirky and somewhat of an oddball
once at a party when asked about his
Hobbies he famously remarked quote well
I like racing cars I have five including
two McLarens and an old Tesla I like
flying rented planes all over California
oh and an odd one I prep for survival
seeing the Burmese look on the faces of
his audience he further explained quote
my problem is that when my friends get
drunk they talk about the ways the world
will end after a Dutch lab modified the
h5n1 bird flu virus five years ago
making it super contagious the chance of
a lethal synthetic virus being released
in the next 20 years well non-zero
the other most popular scenario would be
AI that attacks the US and Nations
fighting with nukes over scarce
resources
just to clarify though Oldman said all
of this in 2016. we all know what
happened three years later in late 2019
as the Wall Street Journal reports
according to American government
officials it was the lackluster
precautions taken at a research lab in
China that caused a deadly virus to
break out and cause the whole world to
experience an insufferable pandemic I'm
not going to get into discussing that
here but the point is Altman was surely
onto something that most people were
oblivious to but what about the scenario
of AI attacking well he took steps to
make sure that this wouldn't happen
we'll get to that later
[Music]
besides his quirky nature he really did
want to change the world but not in a
scummy Elizabeth Holmes kind of way
after selling his first company looped
Sam launched a small Venture fund called
hydrazine Capital it would fund
technology companies in education
Specialty Foods Hospitality consumer
networks enterprise software and
internet connected Hardware
Sam became known for his ability to spot
hidden gems and fix their flaws
interestingly Altman invested in and
briefly served as the CEO of Reddit he
helped the company raise 50 million
dollars in 2014 when it was in shambles
Altman also has a passion for nuclear
energy and has invested and joined on
the boards of multiple fission and
fission startups his reasoning a
challenging business tends to attract
more interest think about it this way so
you want to create another social media
startup if you pitched the idea you'd
probably get a board look from your
potential investors
but if you were to create an AI company
with the computer science know-how to
back it suddenly everyone wants to do
the same thing as Sam progressed in his
professional Endeavors he became a
powerful figure in Silicon Valley as his
mentor Paul Graham notes Sam is
extremely good at becoming powerful
2012 was an interesting year for AI
Jeffrey Hinton releases a seminal paper
the proved for the first time that
neural networks could recognize objects
as accurately as humans in this same
Year in 2012 Altman was out hiking with
some of his friends in the North of San
Francisco they were discussing human
intelligence and AI as the discussion
went on Altman suddenly realized that
humans are not as unique as he thought
he felt that there was no reason to
believe that in 13 years the hardware
could replace the human brain
certain things are still uniquely human
for example genuine creativity
inspiration the ability to feel and to
truly empathize but someday in the
future computers will be able to mimic
the outputs of humans and probably this
is where Sam Altman's fear that one day
AI might destroy humanity and strip us
of our uniqueness began to manifest
he would keep this Revelation close to
his chest until much later in 2016 when
he opened up in an interview to the New
Yorker he said quote there are certain
advantages to being a machine we humans
are limited by our input output rate we
only learn two bits a second so a ton is
lost to a machine we must seem like
slowed down whale songs
he knew machines could someday become
all too powerful and he felt he needed
to do something
Sam Altman was definitely not alone in
his fears another key figure in the tech
World Elon Musk had the same premonition
musk had always been vocal about it
though
while some might think that such a fear
would lead them to avoid the creation of
an AI company altogether they opted for
a different approach doing the exact
opposite
[Music]
2015 Altman and musk would join forces
with other influential figures including
Reed Hoffman co-founder of LinkedIn
Jessica Livingston co-founder of Y
combinator and Peter Thiel
this was in addition to some highly
qualified AI researchers and
entrepreneurs another significant member
who joined the team as Chief scientist
of the company in January 2016 was Ilya
satskova he's a computer scientist
widely respected in the field of machine
learning before joining the musk and
Oldman project he was working at Google
brain as a research scientist
the group pledged over one billion
dollars to fund its operations
they also agreed to make their patents
and research open to the public and to
collaborate freely with other
institutions and researchers hence the
name open AI
initially they set up open AI to be a
non-profit entity that would focus on
creating artificial general intelligence
or AGI AI systems that are generally
smarter than humans but in a safe and
beneficial way they were particularly
concerned that Google's deepmind
Technologies division was seeking to
reign supreme in the field of AI
they thought that Google's Deep Mind
could monitor the world for competitors
and crush them
musk would say in an interview quote if
the AI that they develop goes awry we
risk having an immortal and super
powerful dictator forever he went on
quote murdering all competing AI
researchers as its first move strikes me
as a bit of a character flaw
open AI the non-profit AI research firm
set off with great excitement and lofty
expectations with a star-studded roster
of big name investors and a Grand Vision
for the future the world was eager to
see what they would accomplish
it was quite evident what they feared
but not so much as what they adopted as
their Vision open ai's approach was more
like a curious Explorer constantly
seeking to understand and discover new
things they wanted to create an AI
capable of writing a poem or composing a
symphony but developing an AI system
like this is not easy it requires
patience dedication and a willingness to
embrace the unknown
Sam Oatman explained the system by
comparing it to a child who was just
learning about the world
just like a child an AI system needs
guidance and oversight that's why open
AI planned to create a governance board
that could allow people from all around
the world to have a say in how this
technology is being developed and
deployed
as time went on though it became clear
that there was some fighting in the
ranks
in early 2018 Elon Musk had grown
frustrated with the company's progress
and suggested that he take control of
the operation himself
the other founders of open AI including
Sam Altman and CTO Greg Brockman
declined musk's proposal a power
struggle soon ensued and musk in turn
walked away from the project publicly
though open Ai and musk both cited the
reason as a conflict of interest and
there was some truth to this Tesla was
developing its autonomous driving
program and they had already lured one
of open ai's Engineers for that adding
fuel to the fire was the fact that musk
had promised to donate roughly one
billion dollars to the organization over
a period of years he stopped making
payments after his departure this left
the non-profit in a precarious position
there are astronomical fees associated
with training AI systems on
supercomputers
they were going to have to do something
[Music]
one year earlier in 2017 Google brain
announced a neural network architecture
called the Transformer
it became a popular choice for natural
language processing tasks such as
machine translation and text generation
it was revolutionary in the sense that
any AI system could now be trained and
improved endlessly as long as you can
feed it data but it was costly
to take advantage of the Transformer
model open AI soon made a monumentous
decision they announced that they would
be a for-profit entity capping profits
for investors and funneling any excess
back into the original non-profit Altman
however refused to take any equity in
the new entity
the move to for-profit turned off some
investors but less than six months later
Microsoft joined hands with open Ai and
initially invested one billion dollars
they provided open AI with the cloud
computing infrastructure to train their
massive AI models which eventually
created chat GPT and the image generator
Dali after the huge success of chat GPT
in January 2023 Microsoft announced an
additional 10 billion investment in open
Ai and its technology in return
Microsoft had gained access to some of
the most advanced and popular AI models
in the world and they could deploy it
across their consumer and Enterprise
products at will
[Music]
in some ways the deal with Microsoft was
a deal with the devil it would cause
open AI to diverge from their original
ethos the research is no longer open and
free it's hidden away away from the
prying eyes of competitors
Microsoft urged the company to stay
ahead of the competition and put
pressure to release AI products
Microsoft and open ai's partnership as
well as chat gpt's early success drove
Google into a panic Google has
traditionally kept its AI developments
Under Wraps whereas open AI released
them to the public for General use
and this was the beginning of the famous
AI War which I've talked about a lot
but because these AI tools are still in
their infancy the results have either
been remarkable or absurd thus far why
would anyone release an unfinished
product
according to Sam Oldman the benefits of
democratizing such powerful technology
far outweigh the potential risks of one
individual being in control regardless
the cat is out of the bag now and
countless companies are using AI tools
for developing their own
and in the world of business when you
see your competitor doing something that
generates success there's going to be a
bunch of unlimited copycats government
and the general populace are behind the
United States only had their first
meeting with AI leaders in May of 2023
and I think my question is what kind of
an innovation is it going to be
is it going to be like the printing
press
that diffused knowledge and power and
learning widely across the landscape
that empowered ordinary everyday
individuals that led to Greater
flourishing that led above all to
Greater Liberty
or is it going to be more like the atom
bomb
huge technological breakthrough
but the consequences severe
terrible continue to haunt us to this
day
before we release gpt4 our latest model
we spent over six months conducting
extensive evaluations
external red teaming and dangerous
capability testing
we are proud of the progress that we
made
gpt4 is more likely to respond helpfully
and truthfully
and refuse harmful requests than any
other widely deployed model of similar
capability
however
we think that regulatory intervention by
governments will be critical to mitigate
the risks of increasingly powerful
models and the thing is this is the baby
stages of AI it's only going to get
better with time and fast who knows what
could happen in the distant future it
could be great or not so great
in Sam Altman's own words quote I think
it'd be crazy not to be a little bit
afraid
he also states that super intelligence
and Rogue AI are not immediate threats
the threats that we Face are quite
mundane
misinformation economic shocks his
solution is to ensure that AI safe is
highly aligned with human values and I'd
like to think that the result of this
could make a better world for us all but
we still have to be careful and already
it does miraculous things at Cincinnati
Children's Hospital Dr John pestian and
Dr Tracy glauser are training their own
AI to head off suicide in children it
can give a pediatrician an at a glance
sense of which kids need immediate
intervention an output will say this is
a patient at high risk this is a patient
at low risk where we just don't have
enough data right now roughly 30 to 40
percent of mental illness adult mental
illness started as a child and so you
want to be able to pick that up early
technology has always been a driving
force in shaping our world from the
invention of the wheel to the internet
every new creation has faced its fair
share of criticism we've all seen the
negative sides of the internet how it
can spread misinformation and division
but with AI this is set to only grow
but hey we can't just focus on the
negatives AI is already revolutionizing
game development video production
copywriting coding and countless other
fields it allows the heavy lifting of
cognitive repetitive work that nobody
likes to do to be automated so people
can focus on what they enjoy within
their profession and that's a great
thing that we have to recognize
there are also those who use it as a
tool to enhance their creativity of
course there are negatives but the key
is to use this tool as wisely and
responsibly as possible as Isaac Asimov
the famous science fiction writer once
said quote the saddest aspects of life
right now is that science gathers
knowledge faster than Society gathers
wisdom so let's do our part to not let
that happen use these tools with wisdom
but what about the other side if things
do go very wrong with AI in the future
Sam Oldman may just become one of the
most hated people in history at that
point it might seem like he started off
with pure goals but ended up becoming
the very thing he was trying to prevent
only time will tell ultimately
so that's the story of Sam Altman and
what his philosophies are I just find
this so fascinating hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching and I'll see you
again soon for another video my name is
Togo and you've been watching cold
fusion cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking